[Music]
foreign
so to begin with the 1954 original
Godzilla is more than a monster movie
it's actually in essence a well-aged
commentary or nuclear conflict and the
deadliness of tinkering with the forces
of nature it has since inspired more
than 30 sequels including both Japanese
and American films uniting other Kaiju
and monster characters like Mothra Rodan
and King Kong in a Cinematic Universe
Godzilla has also battled aliens dragons
and many more in his many continuations
while Godzilla is many a Time stated to
appear at least a decade after the end
of World War II here in -1 he will be
making his first landfall in Japan just
weeks after the end of the second world
war and maybe he will disappear and come
back a few years later when Japan is
rebuilding itself only to tear it back
to dust and Rubble to -1 so this brings
us to the topic of comparing -1 with the
original in terms of size design powers
and overall role in the storyline so
let's get to it
firstly we might have a slight error in
our estimation of -1 size and I do
consider it might have to do something
with our desire with the big G being as
big as possible in an earlier video we
got him to be around 60 meters or 200
feet tall and I admit we have to do a
re-estimation of Godzilla minus one
based on the release teaser image that
was showcased yesterday in this image
Godzilla seems to be a bit smaller than
what we had anticipated him to be just a
bit though so by analyzing the wreckage
and the vehicles we see near him in this
photo we can now tell you for sure that
this Godzilla is 10 meters lesser than
what we deemed him to be earlier he is
50 meters or 164 feet tall
so where does that put him in comparison
with the original Godzilla in size
so since this is a reboot of swords and
would probably showcase remade scenes
that were iconic from the first movie
ever minus one Godzilla should also
re-embody the original who was also 50
meters or 164 feet tall that means that
he is in the shower era's size range
meaning he's only a bit shorter than the
Millennium series Godzilla and only 10
meters or 32 feet shorter than gmk and
therefore doesn't come even close to
legendaries Ocean's height never mind
Godzilla Earth but that's good in a lot
of ways because as a 50 meter tall
Godzilla he would be even scarier than
the gargantuan versions who seem to be
oblivious to individual humans at least
on the scale he would be able to
interact with humans in a way which is
more personal and believable and yeah
even the fight with the military would
be more interesting imagine the tanks
and the missile explosions on the
Master's Godzilla in San Francisco being
twice bigger well that's what we would
see with a minus one that is less than
half the size the bells would be more
impactful as well as more frightening
rather than being impersonal as of
shelling a mountain as in the case of
the bigger ones or as you can see in
Godzilla Earth
so let's see the differences between the
design of the should I Goji the first
official Godzilla design and the one in
-1 which are striking in differences
should I Goji features a classic
Godzilla appearance with charcoal gray
scales a small reptilian head with a
white mouth and downward pointing black
pupils and also staggered forward
curving dorsal blades its body is Barrel
shaped with white shoulders short and
muscular legs and plenty great feet in
contrast -1 takes on a more Eldritch and
Sinister appearance with dark brown and
black scales irregular textures its face
resembles the heisei Stan Winston's
final wars hybrid featuring a curved
snout bright yellow eyes with visible
pupils and well-defined teeth the most
distinctive feature is its dorsal plates
which are thorn-like and give a horrific
impression minus one also has massive
theropod like legs with four toe Claws
and also eagle-like Talons on its hands
and a tube-like round tip tail the
entire design exudes a more menacing and
other worldly aesthetic setting it apart
from the traditional Godzilla template
okay let's go on to the atomic breath
which is the primary range attack of
Godzilla and it has been seen since the
first movie and always has never skipped
any of the other versions well except
for the Tri-Star version who had
something of a power breath I don't know
anyway the atomic breath was first
represented as a literal aerosol breath
of radioactive air that could superheat
and Destroy dense materials including
cars steel Towers Bridges and of course
slow-moving Japanese people later
representations of Godzilla's Atomic
breath has taken on the visual
appearance of death rays which will be
seen in this version of -1 as well it'll
have the same effect but having a much
cooler looking and probably deadlier uh
breadth on a large scale it will be
displayed as a concentrated beam of
white or blue energy surrounded by a
blue Corona and yeah whenever Godzilla
is preparing to release this by a weapon
the plates along his spine the dorsal
blades will begin to glow blue as seen
in the release image as well as a
certain scene in the trailer
so with that out of the way let's go on
to his origins in both the continuities
well in the 1954 film Godzilla it was
revealed that the monster was originally
a prehistoric reptile creature from deep
below the ocean floor or on the ocean
floor however its life took a drastic
turn when it became exposed to radiation
from nuclear testing conducted by the
United States in the Pacific Ocean the
massive doses of radiation led to its
rapid growth to an enormous size in this
original timeline filled by anger and
the changes in its habitat as well as
himself Godzilla directed its Fury
towards Humanity he began by destroying
any boats he encountered and eventually
Unleashed his devastating wrath upon the
city of Tokyo showing no mercy to anyone
in his path and as we have seen in the
trailers and the origins teaser of -1 it
seems that this version would follow the
same path although there might be
certain time differences maybe from 1954
in the original to 1947 here in -1 based
on the date and year that is seen in the
letter sent by General Douglas MacArthur
to the Prime Minister of Japan warning
him of a massive aquatic organism which
is none other than Godzilla himself
heading towards the main islands of
Japan
so what do you think oh yeah now that we
have covered their similarities and
differences in this sort of comparison
video Let's ponder about how -1 will be
killed in the movie or whether or not he
will be killed well there are three
possibilities first is the United States
dropping another atomic bomb on him
while he is in Japan furthering the
dangers and message about Atomic weapons
their usage in the world and the dangers
that might lead to you know Mutual
assured destruction
which was also the theme of The Master
himself second they followed on the
footsteps of the original and we get the
oxygen destroy weapon killing him like
it did with the first one and thirdly
he might be either trapped as in the
case of heisei Godzilla or he swims away
for unknown reasons like the monster
verse version
in short he survives for another attack
or another return of Godzilla's sequel
well that sounds fun anyway we have come
to the end of this video and I hope you
have enjoyed watching it do hit the like
button for support and subscribe but
most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates and new videos right
here on this channel especially Godzilla
videos
till the next time take care fam
foreign